everybody welcome to the Rubin report
I'm Dave Rubin I am over the top beyond
bonkers excited for this comedy licious
edition of the Rubin report we have two
ladies with me this week one of them
that I spent every Saturday night with
from 1989 to say 1993 and one of them
that I spent every night of the week
with on a street corner in New York City
from about 2001 to 2006 first we have
miss Jackie
Harry you know her from 2:00 to 7:00
from sister-sister from the first family
right now and man you are really the
hardest working woman in showbiz you
just shot the pilot for Girl Meets World
yeah you doing Jackie oh hi artist
working she works pretty hard too though
oh no this one and this one this
hard-working lady you know her from best
week ever but basically everyone knows
you from is it still the number-one
sitcom yes I'll say on the television
yes this little thing called the Big
Bang Theory yes yes yes that is that is
I and the street-corner qui clarify that
that sounds like we were turning tricks
no what were we doing on the street
corner let's get it out right up front
we were turning tricks and we were also
handing out flyers to see stand-up
comedy yes we Melissa and I survived we
are survivors from the stand-up comedy
days but we'll get back we'll get to
that in just a little bit so I want to
talk comedy we're gonna do this whole
thing about comedy and funny people and
the ladies of comedy so Jack hey we're
gonna start with you comedy where does
it come from are you born with it what's
the deal yes
timing yes obviously fails in it Ronny
danger Tommy baby baby baby if you're
gonna tell me baby baby you ain't funny
bet you cannot joke Chicanos baby gonna
be funny I'd be fine but then jokes
maybe they know the jokes right there
are no new jokes case you'll understand
what I just said yeah but you gotta you
gotta have timing or not you can learn
it to some extent but you got to really
have it you know think you can be a
funny person but maybe not have timing
so that'll throw it off but you gotta
have time and you got to have maybe
these days wit
we'd like to you should be slam bam you
know comedy you know which I loved you
know those old movies uh with that funny
ugh
Carroll would lo eight all those I watch
all that stuff but Lucy's my favorite
yeah comedian you know to this day still
you know she that's physical humor which
I like so you got to have some physical
humor but you know it's like Ellen
DeGeneres is witty yeah you know clever
and did you have it did you when you
were five six years old where they go in
that Jack no you didn't have it that no
it came at sixteen I my girlfriend uh
took me out we cut class third period
and she gave me my first joint okay I
smoking now I got a lit and then I went
to acting class for five years and I
blossomed and that came out you know who
knew I didn't plan on it cuz I was a
dramatic actress I didn't want to do two
to seven it was a comedian I said well
ruin my career cuz I was doing great
things in New York yeah it's like my
girlfriend says I was doing a Moscow on
the Hudson with Robin Williams I had a
movie I had a plan then this little
thing two to seven came along you know I
stole that from the Shell Nichols she
said you know I had a great Caruso at
Pearl Bailey on Broadway she said in
this little thing called Star Trek came
along you know so it all work what you
plan yeah even her sitting out I didn't
know she was stand-up with you I mean
how could I know that you know that you
actually were working stand-up person
you know you know and people look at
your [ __ ] well I should get that job
you know they do don't you think so yeah
don't worry I don't think Jackie is
coming for your gig on no no I know
looking at it I can tell cause it's like
you put to work for it yeah yeah well
let's talk about working for were you
born I know your story but were you born
with it did you just pop out of the womb
going I'm making people laugh I think it
was always definitely like an outlet for
me I was a super shy kid and that was
always my way of like expressing myself
I think and you started Santa when was
your first performance I I remember like
getting my first lap in my parents
living room watching Three's Company and
doing a Don Knotts imitation yeah and my
dad laughing and then that allowed me to
stay up later and then I begged my
parents to let me enter this beauty
pageant and I was not like like a kid
who should have been entering beauty
badges but this flyer came to my house
and it's
there was a Talent Competition and I was
like that's my chance to do stand-up my
Paris toothless and my parents were like
yeah I don't think we should be entering
in a beauty pageant and then they were
like if you save up half the money for
the entry feat and you could do it they
didn't think I would and I did and I we
entered be the beauty pageant well
Melissa we have a crack staff here and
we have attained some of that videotape
1988 this is melissa rauch doing
stand-up comedy for the first time
shock and awe oh yeah that's obsessed
with me I'm amazed I did a lot of
show-and-tell as jackée oh my very pants
yeah yes yes hang off yeah I'm guessing
you've seen a billion Jackie
impression two billion kazoos where does
that fall but top top top 206 right
there no but you know you never think
about that that's what I'm saying you
just do comedy cuz we all copy somebody
and then you make it yours
see that's my thing I don't like people
copying and then continuing to do it you
know I was looking and this is kind of
controversial for me and not for me but
I was looking at taxing the other night
the old series taxi and Jeff Conaway
God rest his soul I loved him we were
great friends and he always said that
John Travolta other people stole his
character from that show and I kept
going what does he mean I see what he
meant I finally got it you know what I
mean you know the little little little
isms I call them you know but when you
make them your own than they're yours
and that's what John Travolta did he
made it his own you know so you can't
somebody steal your stuff this comedian
still y'all know that you go to a comedy
snow you hear your children you all
still we all do but certain people go to
steal Batum oh lot of transformer jokes
all right well let's talk about a little
bit about our beginning stand-up days
now with Jackie you said you did a
little stand-up back in it baby I'm no
good at it out kill people if they don't
laugh yeah I can't stand when they don't
laugh the word Khomeini's you got a
barrel on through right did you like
doing it
oh no no bet you shouldn't have done it
but I was great no I did great I do a
great set I do I took great set you know
but I'm just you know I'm just conscious
that I gotta be fabulous I wanna
most convenience but they go I bombed
you know when you bomb but you know but
then your big it's like what Chris Rock
said you read that he thought he was all
of that he was going around doing his
thing and he's all that the bag of chips
and he said one night before he went on
the opening act came on here the
audience roaring roaring and he's like
what the hell he goes on it's Martin
Lawrence he says like some why did
somebody screw your wife yeah that he
knew the word screw yeah but that's what
everyone can be every comedian fear is
is somebody else getting the bigger
laugh so we did stand-up though for like
six or seven years we stood out on
corners what was it I know what it was
like for me but what was it like for you
it was really it was some tough times I
mean I loved it and I think it
definitely like made me a stronger
person and all that but I think um I the
actual performing was fantastic and I
learned so much but then I think handing
out those flyers on the street started
to break me as a person there was a
moment I remember I think we've spoken
about this I was thinking about coming
out to LA and I was kind of
procrastinating and I was standing on
the street corner handing out flyers and
it was between the early show on The
Late Show so it was like 10:30 11:00
while the Broadway shows were getting
out and I was in this big hoodie and
like fingerless gloves so I could get
the Flyers out and my hands were all
cracked and this little girl comes out
of a Lion King with her mom and as I
come see comedy and she looked at her
mom and she was like mommy that is so
sad
and I just had this meltdown of like
she's entirely right and I need to
rethink my life and then that was kind
of a push to get me to come out to LA to
come out to Sun yelling do you guys ever
miss the old days do you miss before you
were on the sitcoms and before you made
it then and that struggle phase yeah now
I don't miss it at all
nothing no nothing I maybe missed the
way I was I was more trusting weren't
you well I had more friends who I could
actually count on more than two hands
yeah you know what I mean because your
circle gets smaller as you become more
successful but don't people think of it
the other way right they think oh big
star you got money your
have all these great people yeah and
they run through your money in your
house yeah you know and you just learn
to stop trusting I don't you know is
this one of those things where you have
to have your privacy like this big thing
with Reese Witherspoon not to get out
but it's like who knew who cared you
know but it's like in the age of Twitter
and social media everybody's all in your
business yeah well this is probably why
I wanted to bring you two together
because it's like you're kind of on the
same path that
jackée is ahead of you on and it's kind
of cool do you do you I mean you're not
that far out well you were doing
impressions of her when you were seven
I've been gunning for this my entire
life this is everything in my life has
led to this this moment but do you do
you miss what I think of now because
we're out of it as the good old days but
at the time it was pretty rough yeah I
mean there was some there was some tough
time even we got country got paid and
food that restaurant that was later shut
down for food violation literally by the
Board of Health shut down the place we
were working um and that was dinner
every night and um I mean barely cab
fare home um so I mean I wouldn't turn
like trade that in for anything in the
world um what does it seem romantic to
you yet like when you were waiting
tables and things like that does have
you got to that point it it doesn't I
think it's still very very recent me so
yeah I still have my waitressing apron I
think with like food stuck to it or
somewhere I like hanging it on my wall
as a cautionary tale yeah a place I
don't want to go back to but it yeah I
think um there was parts of it though
that were great but um but also you know
there was definitely a struggle there
but I enjoyed it as it was happening
yeah
bonobos calms the official outfitter of
the Reuben report enter code TR r20 for
20% off your first purchase